Well,
you have to do it,
you have to,
you can't just be off for six months and
then step on a stage and expect to be
sort of incomplete possession of your
vocal powers.
So it's a muscle like anything else and
you have to practice and you have to,
uh,
just do it.
And that's what keeps you,
I think going strong.
I can tell you a terrible story.
Well,
not a terrible story,
but a true story.
It's dreadful when you think about it
though.
It was back in the early nineties,
I was touring in Australia with Lucinda
Williams and Rosanne cash and we were
doing these songwriter nights all around
Australia and uh,
every night we and we often share the
same big dressing room or whatever.
And every night Roseanne and Lucinda
would warm up vocally.
And I,
I hadn't quite gotten to that place
where I realized that how important that
was,
you know,
and Roseanne would be in her corner,
a singing scales and doing that sort of
thing.
And Lucinda had some method in her
corner,
just,
I think she would sort of almost bend
over and try to breathe up and stuff and
people would sort of wonder what I would
do and I'd sit in my corner smoking
cigarettes.
That's terrible.
Don't smoke anymore.
I quit that a long time ago.
But that's,
that's how naive I was about how
important it is to take care of your
boys.
I know that a lot of.
I know a lot of artists who smoke say
that and swear by it.
Um,
and uh,
but for me,
no,
I had to,
I had to quit a long time ago.